what's up everyone welcome back to the
channel for an interview I'm very
excited about because I'm obsessed with
the Midnight Club you were all
exceptional I would waste all of my time
right now singing your praises the show
is something else and I hope you all are
very proud thank you thank you I made it
one rapid fire question before we dig
into some spoilers here but let's say
you as in real you were in the Midnight
Club what would your mug look like and
what would be in it
that's a great question maybe I should
have saved it for today
I know what mine is I I know mine okay
um I'm gonna say I would have a wine
glass like a really pretty wine glass
with um
with some Snapple in it yeah
for me it would be one of my eight cat
mugs that I own at home so probably that
and
tea I'm very boring
mine would be of an elephant and the
trunk you would have to drink out of the
trunk and it would be um filled with
Strawberry Fanta
oh
I would go with a crystal goblet and I
would have coffee because I cannot stay
up that late
massive jug and it would be filled with
raw vodka
handmade ceramic blue cup
and it would have hot chocolate but like
Mexican hot chocolate it's like kind of
spicy with um some little marshmallows
in it because why not I don't want to
follow that
um I would have a giant thermos with a
chocolate milkshake
yeah I'd have one of those like German
like big mugs
with lots of beer in it I'm just gonna
no no no no no no just I mean we have a
jug of vodka
all right let's get into some specifics
here before I even touch spoilers Iman
my first question is for you because I
happen to have been listening to the
audiobook and I think it's the coolest
thing ever that you got to play your
character in the show and then you got
to voice so many of the characters in
the audiobook so I was wondering is
there anything you came to appreciate
more about a different character tapping
into them yourself I mean I thought that
it was it was it was just cool to try to
bring to life what everybody did in the
show's adaptation I had a great
appreciation for what uh Chris did with
Spence because his character is just so
Lively in the book and and in the series
and Sandra's character too I had a lot
of fun playing uh Sandra and and
bringing what anara did as well I love
it all right who am I going to come to
next should I put up the spoiler warning
I think I should this is it spoiler
warning we got one question in for that
but spoiler warning if you have not seen
all of the Midnight Club this is it you
push pause you go binge it and then you
come back and press play and it starts
right here that's it all right happening
Ruth I'm coming your way because I've
already said it to you it is astounding
to me that this is your first acting
experience so when you jump into it is
there any particular scene that you
Circle in red and say to yourself This
is the most intimidating of the bunch
for me all of it all of it I remember
like we got the first two Scripts and I
was like how am I going to remember all
these lines and then we got another what
ace and I was like there's more
um but Mike was a brilliant director so
it was and she was such a well-written
character so I think my job was made
I was eased into it slightly a bit a bit
more yeah in the end is there any
particular scene you're most proud of
that you you're going to look back and
say like holy [ __ ] I can't believe I did
that
um
yeah I surprised myself during seven I
think
um
yeah I'm praying I'm proud of seven and
I don't say that very often about myself
but yeah please say it for yourself this
entire series of you for that matter
um ADI I'll come to you next I am
curious if Cherie did tell a story
during the Midnight Club what kind of
story do you think she would tell I
don't know I feel like Cherie is a
little edgy so I feel like she would
tell something
I mean you guys could do this but I
really want to do like a Mad Max kind of
series or something like a kind of weird
like sci-fi like in the desert fighting
for
human rights kind of thing I think
that's kind of what Cherie would lean
towards and I would love to do something
like that this would make me sound
spoiled after getting an excellent
season of the show but now I want like a
bonus episode like uh Netflix did with
Sandman and that could be the story yeah
it would be really cool I have one more
question for you is there any particular
lie that she tells that got cut out or
was just like so outlandish that you got
to play around with it
um
there is
um well I don't know if it was a lie but
it was like when we were on the beach
and I was talking about
Beach High something high school high
pie I don't know what I was saying but I
was like losing it and I was having the
best time and I was laughing like a fool
and nobody else was laughing but but
yeah that was like the one time I like
really went far I think but then it was
super fun now I'm just thinking what was
it deaf pie high yeah exactly that's
because I liked it
um maybe I'll come your way next for a
broader question and actually this isn't
really spoilery but Heather came in
earlier and she was saying a little
something about all of you and for you
she was praising just like how seriously
you take your craft so it was making me
wonder going forward is there any new
tool in your acting toolkit so to speak
that you can credit to Midnight Club
that you're looking forward to exploring
further on a next project absolutely and
I will credit directly to Heather she
taught this wonderful trick about
hitting your mark uh where you walk
backwards from it and and I will give
her all the credit for that because
I definitely miss it 90 of the time that
is probably a really good trick I'm
surprised more people have not said that
um I am sorry and so I am obsessed with
the scene that you have in episode 10
that conversation where you're in
profile you're in the background just
tell me everything about doing that
scene together because from my
perspective it seems like that
particular moment it's just of the
utmost importance to have the ideal
scene partner in each other or it
doesn't work
yeah absolutely I mean the first thing
that comes to mind is I told saurian to
make me cry
I was like you have to try as hard as
you can to make me cry in the scene but
I was a really good crier like she can
turn it on and off so I don't know if
that was uh because you know how to cry
really well so no that was me or that
was just you that was genuine okay yeah
um but yeah I think uh we didn't talk a
lot about that scene beforehand we just
kind of like
okay we know that there's a big heavy
scene coming up and like um it's it's
the first time you see amesh's
vulnerable side and how he's you know
he's really okay this is real it's
coming
this whole time has been you know fun
and games but now it's you know it's
starting to get real and so
I feel like natsuki being by his side is
uh
I don't know I don't think he would want
anybody else to be right there with him
so uh I just I love that scene is an
amazing scene I broke down completely
when I watched that scene oh yeah me too
I just was on the floor crying so it's a
really beautiful moment
um one for you now Chris so one of my
favorite scenes of yours are specific
moments of yours is right after Sandra
tells give me a kiss and apologizes and
you go up to her and you like have a
moment where you look at her and kiss
her on the forehead there is a million
and one ways someone can accept and
respond to an apology so I was wondering
what it was like
collaborating I guess with your director
or Mike figuring out the right way for
him to receive that and then Express how
he feels about it yeah um
I think I think that day I just
I just had to really sit in a watch
anara do her magic I just remember
um anaris such um a uh
a silent weapon I think so so definitely
a black sheep um so quiet in the green
room and then she comes on and she just
kills that monologue and I I just I I
hated Sandra honestly while reading it
was hard for me to
take myself away from Spence I guess and
um I would I would tell Noah I'd be like
oh no I hate it she did this and it's
evil but I think yeah an artist made it
that that's so lovable that it was sorry
um it was easy for me to um forgive her
yeah for sure there's another beautiful
moment in the show when our I'll come to
you next with a a really key reaction
moment for your character when she hears
about her misdiagnosis because that
that's another thing where there's a
whole bunch of different ways that can
be received so what was it like
collaborating with the director on that
episode in order to you know make sure
it was authentic to character yeah I
mean that moment was so hard to figure
out like just reading it too because you
know it is a very joyous thing she gets
another chance at life but she was so
ready and all of her friends were so
ready and she kind of feels like she's
turning her back on them a little bit
you know because she gets to go live her
life
um but yeah like collaborating was
really nice and with Heather too like
she was just giving me all all she had
and it was it was hard but it was really
really cool to like find I guess like a
a new way of expressing it and like I
did a lot of research too like on
YouTube and things like that of like
people our age who are going to the same
thing and you can deal with grief in so
many different ways and I think that
moment she was grieving the life that
she was leaving behind even even though
she was going to you know pass on but
she would miss her friends you know yeah
absolutely
um I'll try to squeezing a couple rapid
fire questions here very quick game this
is my favorite game to play because I
love horror movies we're gonna put you
all in a zombie movie so paint the scene
for you right now paint the picture
there is a zombie outbreak on the set of
the midnight club I'm going to give you
some like superlative type things and
you need to tell me which real person
not the character the real person best
suits it and there's a lot of you so
whoever shouts out the answer first and
explains why that's the right answer who
is the most likely to be the last to
catch on and not realize that there are
zombies on set
I feel like Chris Chris yeah yeah
what the heck how do you feel about that
I mean probably yeah
how about who is the most likely to
sacrifice themselves for the others
double sacrifice
[Applause]
here's another very flattering one I
know who is the most likely to trip and
fall while running from the zombies
oh you can't say me that's ableist
how about this is my favorite one who's
the most likely to get bit and then try
to hide their infection from the group
I need an explanation for this one why
yeah guys why
I feel like he's so strategic yeah yeah
I agree
Maybe
how about who is most likely to be the
last one standing
uh
uh oh yeah yeah
it's tough
I like that the last two here's the last
one this doesn't really happen in zombie
movies but I like asking it who is the
most likely to be turned into a zombie
but be so determined to live that they
fight the change and come back at the
last possible second to help save the
day
I want to say Ruth that gives Ruth
energy
can we go longer
happily but you guys have a panel and
like a whole crowd to wow right now with
that first episode that is filled with
jump scares that's going to entertain
the Comic-Con crowd I'm so excited for
you I can't wait to talk more huge
congratulations on the Midnight Club